[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH LIVNI: Hi, everybody.
My name is Josh Livni.
I have Paul Saxman here with me
at our Google Maps garage.
Today, we have a couple
interesting topics.
We're going to be talking about
bringing vector data
into the Google Maps API,
and then making
it look really great.
Paul will be doing the
looking great part.
So before we get started, I
wanted to have a couple
announcements.
Here on my screen, you can see
that we have our Tracks API--
the Google Maps Tracks API.
It's a pretty cool API.
Over in the left-hand panel,
you can get an idea.
It does nice things like
geofences, and basically lets
you track assets of any kind.
So if you have moving objects,
you want to be able to see
where they're going, do some
sort of things like snap them
to road automatically.
It's a cool API to check out,
and an announcement is that we
have 23 assets that
you can track.
So if you want to get started,
just sign up, and you can
track up to 20 objects moving
around for free.
So that's a pretty cool API.
Second announcement
of the day--
some upcoming changes to the
way we're sending out the
versions of the Maps
v3 JavaScript API.
So starting in about a week,
we're going to change the
default such that if you don't
specify a version, which you
can always do-- if you want the,
for example, experimental
version versus stable version,
the release version.
Previously, by default, you got
the release version, and
in the future, by default, if
you don't specify, you'll get
the experimental version--
unless you're a Maps for
Business customer, and with
your client ID, in which
case, you'll still
get the release version.
So check out the Google Maps API
v3 Notify group for more
info there.
PAUL SAXMAN: And just a couple
quick notes on the version.
So the versions, we
always have three.
We have a frozen version, the
release version, and the
experimental.
So you can pick any one
of those three.
And if you do V equals 3, I
think you get the release
version, right?
JOSH LIVNI: Correct.
PAUL SAXMAN: So if you still
want to keep the release
version, when you actually load
the JS library, specify V
equals 3, and everything
will work exactly
the way it does now.
But if you don't specify, which
I usually don't, because
I just like to rely on the
JavaScript library to do the
work for me, you'll actually
switch over to experimental,
which is probably a good
thing, because--
JOSH LIVNI: Yep.
You get the bleeding edge
features, and you can play
around with the new stuff.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
JOSH LIVNI: OK, cool.
That's our announcements.
And today's topic is Let's Make
a Map, except for the
Google Maps API.
This is a really cool blog
post by this guy, Mike
Bostock, who amongst many other
things that he's done,
which are amazing, wrote
a library called D3.
Very nice SVG graphics library
being used increasingly around
the web to make cool looking
things, including maps.
It has a very nice
geo extension.
And in addition to that, he
came up with this kind of
specification called TopoJSON,
which we'll talk about a
little bit more.
But basically, it's a great way
to kind of compress vector
data and bring it into
a map of your choice.
So this blog post that he wrote
a couple months ago, he
kind of walks you through the
steps of how you might do it--
find some data, convert the
data to the appropriate
formats, such as GeoJSON, and
from there to TopoJSON.
And part of that is installing
some software
tools on your computer.
And it's a really great step
by step walkthrough that I
recommend you guys
read if you want.
What we're going to do today
is show you a couple tools
that makes it even easier to
get through some of these
steps without installing your
own software, and talk a
little bit about the different
kinds of formats that we have
when we're working with geo
data, and how you want to get
this data from around the web.
So just to introduce a couple of
terms, there's this format
called GeoJSON.
And it's basically just a way
of storing vector data and
sending it around the web,
if you feel so inclined.
It's a legitimate
specification--
lots of smart people
worked on it.
It's used by lots of different
services around the web,
including some of our own, like
Maps Engine, for example,
will use GeoJSON in its API, if
you make a request to that.
Fusion Tables similarly gives
you GeoJSON output.
And so it's a very nice
interoperable way to send
things around.
PAUL SAXMAN: So geometry is--
a really nice thing about it
is you can also put feature
information as well, right?
So the geometries are things
like your polygons, polylines,
and points on the map.
And then also the feature data
is stuff like population,
length of roads, names
of countries.
JOSH LIVNI: All of
the attributes.
PAUL SAXMAN: Exactly.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, exactly.
So good point.
We have what we call a feature,
and a feature is a
combination of the geometry and
the associated attributes.
So anyway, that's a way that
you might see spatial data
sort of transferred
around the web.
But you don't see a lot
of it stored on the
web in GeoJSON format.
This new format I'm mentioning,
TopoJSON, is
pretty cool.
And it has some topology built
into it, which lets you do all
kinds of stuff that I'm not
going to go into today.
But it's nice.
And it also allows you a little
bit smaller file size
by generalizing the features,
sort of losing some of the
accuracy of the geometries, and
it's up to you how you set
how much accuracy you want for
your needs with the map.
But you often end up with an
easy way to send a smaller
file size around.
PAUL SAXMAN: And it can be a
little or a lot smaller.
Sometimes I've seen, if you get
rid of all of the feature
data and just go with the
geometry data, like maybe 10%
of the file size
of the GeoJSON.
But it really depends on the
file, the complexity of the
data you're dealing with.
But it does things like
compresses, so shared borders
on polygons get compressed into
just one line, and that
type of thing.
So it's a very nice
compact format.
JOSH LIVNI: Indeed, yeah.
So I definitely recommend
you guys read the
wiki page on TopoJSON.
It's licensed, I think, under
a BSD license, and
everything's available
on GitHub.
And there's great documentation
and so forth.
So next thing I just want
to talk briefly
about is the shapefile.
This is a very common format
that you find when you're
actually looking for spatial
data around the web.
If you're like, oh, where do I
get zip codes, or where do I
get partial boundaries for some
city, or whatever it is,
it often comes in a shapefile,
which is--
it's been around a while,
that format.
And it's a confusing name.
So here I am at the West
Sacramento GIS download site.
And you can see that in the
description here, we have some
polygons for the city limits.
I'm going to go ahead and
download the Schools
shapefile, which has
both polygons and
points in the shapefile.
Which is kind of an interesting
thing because
shapefiles, unless you have a
multi-geometry, don't support
different types of geometries
in the same thing.
I'm going to go ahead and
open up this shapefile.
And you'll see inside this
shapefile, there's actually
like 10, 15 files.
Kind of confusing.
A shapefile is made up from
anywhere between, say, three
and six files.
Some of them you care about
more than others.
Some are some metadata talking
about projections, and maybe
other types of metadata about
the file, some are the
geometries, some are
the attributes.
This particular zipped archive,
you'll see there's
actually two shapefiles--
a point shapefile, and then
this polygon set of
shapefiles, and they're
all zipped
into this one shapefile.
So how do we get
this on a map?
That's kind of the
topic of the day.
You come across this, you want
to get the school boundaries
and points on a map.
How do you do it?
So you could follow that
article we previously
mentioned on how
to make a map.
It will walk you through it.
What we have here is a tool I
put together about a year or
two ago that takes
shapefiles--
it's called Shape Escape--
and converts them.
Previously uploads them to
Fusion tables, and now I've
added a feature that
converts them into
either GeoJSON or TopoJSON.
So let's walk through it here.
You go to Shape Escape--
shpescape.com--
click on the GeoJSON to TopoJSON
conversion, wait a
little while.
Beautiful UI here.
Select your file.
We'll go ahead and select the
zip file we just downloaded.
I'll hit Upload.
Wait a little while for it to
upload, parse, convert into
their various formats.
And you'll see on the left here,
in the panel, we have
three files that came
out as a result.
We have the polygon features,
which I can download in
GeoJSON format.
The point features, which I can
download in GeoJSON format.
And the TopoJSON, which is the
combination of these two
together in one single
TopoJSON file,
which is kind of cool.
It makes it easy to merge lots
of different data sets.
So if you had states and
counties, you could put them
in one zip file, upload it to
this tool, and get a single
TopoJSON out with all the
borders shared appropriately,
and so forth.
And then I can go ahead and
display one of these.
And you can see that in this
particular case, it zooms at
Sacramento, and you can see the
polygons and the points.
So this is just a really easy
way, given a shapefile, that
you can get it into Maps API.
I'm not going to go too much
into the code behind this.
It's open source.
You can download the code,
that's what does the
conversion and so forth.
If you want, you can go
ahead and view source.
Always a great idea to look at
how I displayed it on a map.
I'll just very briefly walk
through how I made the map.
First, of course, I styled
the map to make it a nice
grayscale, so the base
map doesn't take
away from my data.
PAUL SAXMAN: Zoom in.
JOSH LIVNI: Ah, yes.
Zoom in.
Thank you.
I initialize my map, and then
I just have a couple real
simple methods to display the
TopoJSON, and that's actually
the entire thing right there,
these three methods.
So it's about probably
30 lines of code to
do that whole business.
And the reason that it's so
quick is I am able to take
advantage of this
other library--
the GeoJSON to Google
Maps library.
I just want to give a shout
out to Jason Sanford, who
wrote this other cool library
that makes it super easy,
given a GeoJSON file, to display
it into Google Maps.
So that's the final piece
of the puzzle.
We have shapefiles, convert them
to GeoJSON, convert them
to TopoJSON, bring them into
Maps API using this great
library, and if you use Shape
Escape, in 15 seconds, you
have your shapefile on a map.
On the other hand, the map does
not look super beautiful.
I mean, it's fine.
So Paul is going to show
us how to remedy that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So what I can do is just show
a couple examples of why you
might want to pull shapefiles
into a map, and how you can
actually style it and make it--
what you can do with it,
essentially.
So what I did here--
so I actually went to
Natural Earth data.
We've talked about Natural Earth
data quite a bit before.
They have a lot of real
great geometry data.
And then they also actually
pack in a bunch of feature
data as well.
So, for example, in their
populated places dataset, they
include all the information
about populated places.
These are cities or metropolitan
areas.
But they also contain things
like population, area, that
type of thing.
So if you have that data, you
can actually pull the places
into your map, but then also do
things like do some actual
data analysis using your map.
So what I did here--
this is actually just a map.
So I followed the technique that
Josh mentioned before.
I went to the Natural Earth
data website, I downloaded
their populated places
dataset for the--
I think this is the 110
million dataset.
Loaded it into Shape Escape, got
the TopoJSON file out, and
then just started coding
things up.
So I was re-importing the
TopoJSON into my map, and
converting it to an object using
the TopoJSON library,
using the GeoJSON library
to get the polygons out.
It sounds like a lot of work,
but it's literally two lines
of code to go from your file to
the TopoJSON, or the object
format using the TopoJSON
library, and then another line
of code to go from the objects
to polygons, or to geometry
data that you can put
into Google Map.
So yeah, pretty much what I did
is I just took that data,
I sorted based on the
population, and plotted the
top 100 on a map.
I also did, obviously,
some map styling.
A couple other things that I
added in here real quick--
and I'll show you the
code in a moment.
But I did things like
info windows.
So you can pretty easily, since
these are Google Maps
geometry objects, adding info
windows on top of them is
really easy.
Also, I should note that
these are actually not
just standard markers.
So these are actually
our vector markers--
our symbols.
So that's how I'm able
to kind of scale
them relatively easily.
And the other thing
about this--
I scaled them based on the--
so the areas are equivalent
to the population.
So you can see pretty quickly on
this map, actually see the
most populated places around
the world, where they're
centered, that type of thing.
So this is, literally, like I
said, it's maybe like 80 lines
of code total to get all this
data in and actually get it
styled the way I like it.
We can take a look.
And actually, a big chunk of
that is the map styling code.
So this is the city's
.html file.
So literally, it's just actually
loading all the
scripts, all the relevant
information, and then setting
up my map canvas.
And so really, the code, or the
stuff that really matters,
is in the JS file.
So just to run through it real
quick, we have the style
initialization.
This is how I get the dark
look with the background.
We've talked about the map
styling quite a bit in other
shows, so I definitely recommend
you go back and
check one of those out
if you're curious.
But the trick to all this is
always using the Styled Maps
Wizard, because the Styled Maps
Wizard is kind of just
dragging some sliders around
to actually get
the style you want.
Setting up my map.
So here, I'm just basically
setting up the map with pretty
much standard settings, but then
applying my style to it.
And this was a little bit
tricky, a little bit of code.
This is kind of generalized.
What I wanted to do
is the JSON file.
So when you convert to TopoJSON,
it actually takes
the geometry collection name and
actually assigns that to
an object in your object
hierarchy, in
the TopoJSON hierarchy.
So if you don't know that name
ahead of time, like, for
example, if you're swapping
files around, or swapping
geometries around--
for example, if you're going
from the 10 million to the 110
million, you need to actually
change that in your code.
This line of code actually just
generalizes it, so I'm
just actually getting the
first property of the
geometries object.
And then basically going
through, using the TopoJSON
library to do the conversion
from the
TopoJSON back to GeoJSON.
Next up, what I'm doing is I
want to go through the GeoJSON
properties.
No, so next thing I'm doing is
actually doing the sorting,
because what I did is from
TopoJSON to GeoJSON, I
preserved the feature
information.
So I can actually sort before
I actually do the conversion
to Google Maps geometry
objects.
So I do the sorting on the data,
I trim down my list to
the top 100 cities, and then
I actually call the GeoJSON
library to convert the GeoJSON
to Google Maps geometries.
The library actually has a
really nice feature, is that--
well, actually, I didn't
use it here.
You can specify features,
actually, when you do the
conversion, so it'll just apply
styling guidelines to
the geometries as it does
the conversion.
I actually do it after the fact,
because I want to drop
in kind of a fairly complex
icon, and that's where I'm
doing the sizing
of the symbol.
So here, I'm actually doing all
the styling, getting it to
look like I want it to for the
symbol, and then here, I'm
actually doing the scaling
to get to the right size.
So at this point, this
geometries object just has a
bunch of Google Maps geometries
or polygons.
No, actually, in this
case it's markers.
So now I'm going
to go through.
Here's where I actually go
through and assign the info
windows, and assign the
geometries to the map.
And that's pretty much it.
It's about 85 lines of code.
If you took out the styling,
we're looking at relatively
like, maybe 50 lines of code
to get all this done.
And the map is--
I think it's actually
compelling.
I don't think it would be--
I'd probably want to look at
this data a little bit more
before I actually ship this,
because there are some
interesting things.
You can see, where was that?
Oh, Osaka and Kyoto.
It's debatable, I guess, whether
or not those are
metropolitan areas
or a metroplex.
And also things like
South Korea.
You see the--
Incheon actually is not
considered part of Seoul,
which, depending on how you
slice the data, you may want
to consider it to be
part of Seoul.
So pretty quick and easy way to
get the data in your map.
Pretty fun, I think.
So there's a lot of other data
in there, like another
visualization I was thinking
about doing would be to do
population density.
Like, rank the cities based on
population density, and then
display size, or correlate
the size of the symbol to
population density, which will
give you a quick way to see
where everybody lives
in the world.
So that's it with that map.
I'm going to rattle through
just a couple more.
So this one's actually a little
more complex, and a
little more interesting from a
Google Maps and data story.
So what I did here is I'm
pulling in the administrative.
So it's the Natural Earth 10
million administrative data.
So this is the country data.
And that actually includes
income groups.
So I think it has five or six
different income groups.
So each country is assigned
an income group.
And then I'm just loading in
the geometry, and coloring
each country by its
income group.
So you can pretty easily
see, I think it's
kind of reverse color.
So dark is actually
high income, and
light is low income.
So one interesting thing about
this is there are no Google
Maps tiles in this map.
So one thing that I did, because
I actually have my own
geometry data for countries, I
just took off all the Google
Maps geometries.
Another really cool
thing about this--
so essentially, I'm using the
Natural Earth data, but then
just using the slippy map
interface from Google Maps.
The thing that I like about
doing this technique is that
we can zoom into any level.
We can actually get into looking
at these countries in
central Europe.
Actually, it's not so
interesting in this map,
because I think the smaller
countries in central Europe
are all kind of homogeneous.
If we go over to this map--
what I did here is same
interface, same dataset.
But instead, I'm actually doing
it by per capita GDP.
So GDP for country divided
by the number of
people in the country.
And as you zoom in here, we
look in central Europe.
We could see things like
Liechtenstein.
JOSH LIVNI: Kind of
pops out there.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, it kind of
pops out really nicely as kind
of a very high GDP, low
population country.
You can also see--
I think it's Qatar down
here, and Kuwait,
kind of pop out nicely.
And you see these very small
countries in this
visualization, just because
you can zoom
in relatively easily.
This is all done using the
Google Maps API, does all the
vector scaling as we
zoom in and out.
Nothing.
So another point was, so this
is actually the same data.
Continent is also part of
the feature information.
So you can really easily just
strip out whatever data you
don't want.
So if you just want to
do a visualization--
the same visualization for
a particular country or
continent, you can do that
relatively easily.
So here, as I'm loading the
data, I'm just saying, like,
if the continent isn't Africa,
I'm just not going to display
it on the map.
You can also, pretty
easily, I think--
that was kind of a nice
feature of what we did
recently, or what Luke did
recently with the Mercator
projection puzzle.
So you could actually move
these geometries
around if you want.
So I was thinking about doing
this as a demo is, instead of
using Africa, I could display
the United States, and maybe
grab Hawaii and--
JOSH LIVNI: Alaska.
PAUL SAXMAN: Alaska.
Thank you very much.
And move them over closer to the
map, so you can actually
see them in context, as opposed
to actually having
them separated out.
So that's pretty much it.
So two different techniques
here.
So one, I'm actually just
pulling in the point
information.
So that's for the cities, using
the feature data from
Natural Earth, and then
scaling the symbols.
The other one, I'm actually just
getting rid of the map
tile entirely, and using
somebody else's geometry data.
Both work pretty easily.
I think it's worth pointing out,
and I think it's worth to
do, is always put in attribution
for where you're
getting the data from.
And also be careful about how
the data is licensed.
I'll take a quick look at this
code, just to show you the one
bit about how you can
filter out the--
JOSH LIVNI: Other continents?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so you can
get rid of the tiles.
So what I just did is
I set up a map type.
So with Google Maps API, you
can do the custom map type.
So I basically just made
my own map type.
So the general map types are
things like road map,
satellite, hybrid,
and terrain map.
So what I did is I just created
my own map type, I'm
generating my own tiles, and
the tiles are just empty.
And what that does is since I'm
using my own tiles, you
won't see the Google Maps
attribution on the map,
because there is no Google Maps
feature data actually
displayed in the map.
So what I had done previously,
and I thought was kind of an
interesting technique, too, is
you can actually use map
styling and just make everything
invisible.
But if you do that, the actual
features are still coming
across over the wire,
and I think they're
just not being displayed.
And you will still see the
Google Maps attribution, or
the tile attribution, so it'll
say where the source of the
information is-- the Google
Maps information.
So this is just a really nice
way to actually get the Google
Maps tiles out and display
your own geometry data.
That's pretty much it.
One other one--
I've been playing around with
roads, so the cities are
really a nice case for
points or markers.
So the administrative is a nice
story around polygons or
complex geometries.
You can also load in-- so the
GeoJSON and TopoJSON also
support polylines as well.
So I've been playing around with
roads and trying to come
up with a compelling or fun
visualization for roads.
The other thing I was thinking
might be interesting would be
do things like symbols.
You could actually put symbols
on the road polylines that
show the flow of traffic,
or something like that.
JOSH LIVNI: Some arrows,
some dashes.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, yeah.
So there's some fun stuff we
could do, and we'll see in the
next couple weeks if we can come
up with something good.
So we're putting some of this
data up, or some of these
files up on Gist.
So if you want to check it out,
this is actually-- just
search for me, Saxman, and
the cities is the first
one that I put up.
We'll put the other
visualizations up so you can
take a look and tweak
them to your liking.
With that, I think that's
pretty much everything.
Josh, you have anything?
JOSH LIVNI: Nope.
I mean, I think the summary is
that it should be really easy
to grab some vector data that
you see around the web.
Whatever the format is, if you
see it in GeoJSON, great.
More likely, if you see it
in a shapefile, don't be
intimidated.
You can easily get it into a map
pretty quickly, and give
it some nice styling.
The whole thing shouldn't
take too long.
So hopefully this helps some of
you guys get up to speed on
what is a shapefile, how do I
get it in, and how do I make
it look nice?
And I look forward to seeing
you guys next week.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, definitely.
And if you have any questions,
feel free to post them either
in the YouTube channel or
Google+, and we'll try to get
back to them.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, absolutely.
And if you have feature requests
for Shape Escape, or
you want to see some more
examples online, I'd love to
hear about it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Thanks
for tuning in.
JOSH LIVNI: Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]